il y avait une autre chose c'est qu'il y
avait eu une influence américaine et en
même temps c'était très français happy
vous même vous aimiez beaucoup
l'amérique vous aviez vous aviez danser
oui enfin comment dirais-je mois sont
les films les grands films d'avant
guerre les grandes comédies musicales
kim avait terriblement marqué et avant
de venir la radio proprement dit j'étais
pardon j'ai été trois ans dans leurs
caisses
chaque elian où je faisais avec nos
modestes moyens français on essayé de
recréer justement cette ambiance des
films américains des grands films
américains des grandes comédies
américaines de l'avant guerre
et lorsque le
lorsque j'ai évolué vers l'animation au
proprement dit ça va bouillir
ça va vous dire c'est un petit peu plus
tard le feuilleton ça va bouillir est
arrivé un petit peu plus tard dans les
années 20 des années 50 début des années
mais lorsque par exemple on a démarré
fait démarrer sous le chapiteau du radio
circus le quitte ou double le quitte ou
double et est une émission qui avait
déjà son husky a vécu ses heures de
gloire en amérique sous le titre de bol
on nothing
et lorsqu'on a démarré le quitte ou
double lorsque j'ai démarré le quitte ou
double en 1950 il n'était pas question
de faire une émission américaine n'ont
rien ne le permettait pas puisque sous
un chapiteau itinérant ne peut pas avoir
de girls on ne peut pas avoir fait tout
ce qu'il fait là les shows à
l'américaine et on a été obligés de
franciser dans le louis merlin qui est
elle mon patron direct à l'époque a
beaucoup regretté de ne pas pouvoir
faire justement cette émission telle
elle était présentée en amérique
[Musique]